- Even villains, you know,
need a little bit of joy,
and company in their life.
Everyone just wants love really.
(creepy music)
(evil laughter)
- I love Disney so much.
- That makes sense, that
makes a lotta sense.
- I really do.
- I like Disney movies.
- I like the old Disney movies, sure.
- There are so many
great villains out there,
they're probably, like,
the most fun parts to play.
- I wanna be Jafar.
(laughter)
I wanna get Jafar, because his figure
is very slender, and snake like.
- I feel like in all of the Disney movies,
there's always this moment
between right and wrong,
and you always think
you'll do the right thing
but I think most of us would actually
end up doing the wrong thing.
♪ Time to take a quiz ♪
♪ Time to take a free- ♪
♪ quiz ♪
- Number one, what is
your greatest quality?
- Being manipulative.
(evil laughter)
- Being sinister.
- Being vain.
- Being sadistic.
- Being ambitious.
- I'm gonna say being ambitious.
- I would say for myself being ambitious.
- I'm also gonna say ambitious.
- I'm gonna say being ambitious.
- Alright, good job, being ambitious.
- What is your ideal lair?
- A castle deep in the woods.
- A castle atop a mountain.
- A palace in a kingdom.
- Out in the wild in a cave.
- Deep in the (bleep) woods, dawg,
like a castle in the woods sounds like,
like amazing.
- Castle on a mountain, love mountains.
High and above everyone else,
and far away and hard to get to.
- My ideal lair.
Do I want a palace in the kingdom
or do I want a palace on a mountain.
It always scares me because
no one could hear you scream.
Mountain, I want a castle
on top of a mountain.
- I'm gonna say a castle on a mountain
because if you're a
castle deep in the woods
people are gonna stumble upon your castle,
and be like "what's going on in here?"
and you're like,
- and try to eat your porridge
"ahh, I have to imprison you now."
- How would you describe your style?
Elegant but powerful.
(evil laughter)
Mysterious.
- Beautiful and regal.
Minimal but still intimidating.
Glamorous.
- I pick minimal but still
intimidating, I'd say.
- I'm gonna say minimal
but still intimidating.
(laughter)
Sometimes I'll wear just
like a simple sweater,
but then I turn to the side,
and I'm like booty, you know?
- Booty.
- I would say mysterious
because I've been looking
for a cowl neck sweater
for about three years now, so...
- You've been looking
for it for three years?
- Yeah, I want a good one.
- You're like my grandfather,
he was looking for a good
soup spoon for years,
and he finally bought one,
well he asked to buy
one from Cracker Barrel,
and they just gave it to him,
and now he keeps it in his pocket.
- Nice.
- Never know when you're gonna get soup.
- No.
- I'm gonna go elegant but powerful,
because I'm attracted to those words.
- How would you prefer your sidekick?
- Wisecracking.
- Cunning.
- Insane.
- Sly.
- I don't like sidekicks.
- I wanna say wisecracking because Lago,
but the seclusion is kinda the reason
why I have a lair deep in the woods,
no sidekicks.
- I don't like sidekicks, I'm on my own.
- No, I need a sidekick.
- Wisecracking, I'd like my
sidekick to be wisecracking.
- My sidekick will probably be cunning,
because wow what a dangerous combination.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
What is the best motivation to be evil?
For revenge, to obtain power.
- Out of jealousy, out of pride, or spite.
- Revenge.
- It's all about the revenge.
- Yeah it's easily revenge.
- Everything I've ever done
in my life ever has been
because someone didn't love me.
- Revenge is about justice.
- It is.
- Revenge.
(evil laughter)
- Okay.
What is the best accessory
a villain can have?
- A staff.
- A cauldron.
- A crystal ball.
- Long robes.
- Or none.
- (bleep) long robes, dawg.
- I knew it.
- I would love, gotta
have those long robes.
- Staff, easy.
- When you're at a
wedding you see the bride
walk down the aisle,
and she's got that long
what is it called, train?
Long train behind her, and you just like,
man that's the dopest part of the dress.
I wanna robe that's as long
as a wedding gowns train.
- He just wants to wear a wedding dress.
- Who knows what's gonna
come outta that staff.
Flames, ice, snakes, who knows.
It's a (bleep) staff for me.
- Yeah, I'm gonna stay staff
because it's like a subtle weapon.
- But also you can be like,
"oh I'm an old lady who
needs a walking stick,"
kapow!
- Yeah, like, "oh I can't walk."
- Real Gandolf like, you know?
- I pick a cauldron because
potions are so much fun.
Love a good cocktail.
- Which of these powers is the best?
- Ability to hypnotize people.
- The ability to metamorphose.
- Being able to put curses on people.
- Being able to use magic spells.
- Just plain old brute strength.
(evil laughter)
- I think magic spells,
oh (bleep) I'm gonna get Maleficent
or whatever she is.
- Yeah, you're gonna get Maleficent.
- I'm gonna go with the
ability to metamorphose,
even though I don't completely understand
what that word means,
but I think if it's like you
can change your appearance.
- Mmm.
- That's one of the scariest
things in a villain,
I could turn into somebody that you love,
and I could really
(bleep) some (bleep) up.
- I don't like that, this
is getting really dark.
(laughter)
- I'm gonna say just
plain old brute strength.
- I'm gonna say magic spells
because as somebody
who is a bruja herself,
which is a witch, nah,
I mean practicing okay,
but a good bruja okay?
- Okay.
- It's versatile, you can
make any sorts of spells
to make people love you
which I have not tried to do.
- What are your power colors?
- Orange and brown.
- Black and red.
- Red and purple.
- Purple and black.
- Black and gray.
- Black and red, it looks very sinister.
- I don't know, these are all evil.
- I'm going purple and black.
- Purple and black.
- I love purple, and I love black.
- I would've picked
purple, black, and blue,
but I'll just stick with purple and black.
- You're gonna get Maleficent.
- I'm gonna say red and purple.
- Nice.
- What is your weapon of choice?
(evil laughter)
A staff, a henchman - no
need to get my hands dirty,
magic of course, teeth
and claws, transformation.
- I would do magic, of course.
- Magic, of course, doi.
- Every villain needs a
henchman, people to die first.
- So you have a sidekick and a henchman?
- I have a sidekick,
- What are you doing?
A henchman, a staff, and
the ability to metamorphose,
I'm (bleep) indestructible.
- I think I would do transformation.
- Which of these do you hate the most?
True love, beauty, family,
not being included, those with more power.
Not being included!
- Those with more power.
- I think, not being included.
- Yeah, I'd say not being included.
- I'm not gonna have
anyone out-villain me.
In every movie the villain always loses,
my movie will be the one
where the villain wins.
- Will I be included?
- Sure, yeah you can come.
But I will have more power than you.
What is the best way to
get back at your enemies?
Embarrassing them, put a curse on them,
emotionally manipulating them,
emotionally manipulating
one of their loved ones,
or killing them.
- They gotta die, dawg.
(evil laughter)
They gotta go.
- I think embarrass them,
hopefully then they'll turn it in to,
they'll go down the comedy route
instead of the revenge route.
- Yeah, what?
- Think about the person
who's done you dirty.
- Done me dirty.
- Done you wrong.
- I'm gonna go with embarrassing them.
- Okay, embarrassing them.
- Yeah, I would just
embarrass them I guess.
- No, they gotta go.
- Or curse them.
- You want them to suffer,
I don't want them in my life at all.
- No, but cursing them could be funny,
it could be suffering but not bad,
sort of like every time
you order chicken fingers
you're given sliced
apple, and it's like gahh.
Every time you go to have
some sort of delicious treat
you get (bleep) fruit instead.
Your biggest fear is,
sword through the heart,
falling off a cliff,
having a boulder fall on you,
being entrapped in a small space,
being struck by lightning.
- The evil queen got struck by lightning,
and then the boulder fell on her.
- Right, so like a double whammy.
- So, I'm gonna say boulder falling on me.
- Sword through the heart,
because that is very painful,
and then you start to gurgle
blood and all that stuff,
and I don't want that.
- Entrapped in a small space,
everything else will kill
me relatively quickly.
- Mine's probably being
entrapped in a small space,
(bleed) I'm gonna get Jafar.
- Yeah.
(triumphant horns)
- [Man Off Screen] Garrick
you are the Evil Queen.
- From...
- [Man Off Screen] Snow White.
(laughter)
- Oh, nice. Okay.
- [Kate] That's the one who's
the fairest of them all, right?
You just need to be the prettiest,
you're mad if you're not the prettiest.
- [Garrick) Oh, that's okay, yep.
- Who am I?
- [Man Off Screen] Kate,
you are Maleficent.
- I knew it.
- Yeah, there it is.
- [Kate] Purple and black, got me.
- Well at least you get
to turn into a dragon.
- Really? Oh hell yeah.
This is awesome, I get to breath fire.
- You get to breath fire, green fire.
- This is the best day of my life.
- [Man Off Screen] Maya,
you are the Evil Queen
from Snow White.
- I knew it. I will admit
I am a jealous person,
and sometimes I'm like,
"mirror what the hell?"
- Yeah.
- Like, what's going on?
Why is she getting more than me?
- [Man Off Screen] Niki,
you are Maleficent.
(laughter)
- That's dope.
She's got wings.
Which Maleficent are we dealing with here?
The Angelina Jolie one, or the cartoon?
- Oh no, the OG.
- Okay, well either way
Maleficent's a bad ass bitch.
- I think every Disney
villain had a reason.
- Yeah.
- Had a pretty good
reason to be mad and sad.
- They have problems,
they have stuff that
they're working through.
- They're just people.
- Also it was different then,
they didn't have access to
like, mental health care
that we do now, so they didn't
know what to do with it.
- Yeah, they didn't have, like iPods.
- See those are just people
who needed help, iPods?
- Can you do, like a maniacal laugh?
(maniacal laughter)
- Nice.
- Thank you.
(dramatic orchestral music)
(thunder cracking)